I could never do this I could never do
this
easy impressive I love this
they hate each other so much you jealous
man this dude is jealous she's stronger
so jealous she's stronger she's always
been stronger
okay rude
they cut out the middle fingers
the trampoline down there it's like
putting a Target on your back in the
backs of all the people you care about
oh cool
all right here's what they all say you
should just give everyone Hulk powers
just bleed on everybody right
and then you don't have to worry about
the target
[Music]
that makes more sense
yes
[Music]
that's pretty dope just a buzz only is
it I'm drunk I think we have some new
Rockstar sponsors that give you all buzz
and no barf
manscapes
that Bluetooth Buzz is my favorite
welcome back to new rock stars
she-hulk's newest scene reveals that
hulks metabolize alcohol faster so that
for them life for Steve Rogers it's all
Buzz no bars but Jen blames Bruce for
this and it seems like it was just a
matter of getting his blood on her so
what really happened there she what
working catchphrase
this is inside Marvel it's new
Rockstar's weekly Marvel reaction show
and She-Hulk season is upon us so
joining me to talk about this are two of
the biggest Marvel nerds I know and
lovers of She-Hulk empty and Jessica
Clemens welcome to you both
season has will almost begun but it's
almost upon us I cannot wait it's almost
like Christmas but less red and more
green green is coming
can you just do that can we make this a
new Game of Thrones and just make it
green is coming and she just green is
coming I feel like we'll uh get a lot of
uh potheads hopes up it's like green is
coming what never mind never mind thank
God it's not April get out of here
hey we we don't turn away any uh of you
I was about to say we don't turn away
anyone who uses here we don't we don't
use shame here
hey I'm dressed as a teacher for a
reason actually as soon as you guys
asked me I was like I'm gonna dress like
a lawyer and I don't think this is a
lawyer
I was trying what are you talking about
you look like a judge you know the whole
a whole judge right now I dig it yeah
the strawberries it's great I mean I
just literally wear the same shirt I I
sleep in and I just roll literally into
the dungeon and start hitting the board
seriously I wear the same outfit like an
Arthur character someone commented
recently saying Eric looks like he
stinks and I feel bad for his fiancee
that was me that was me in the comments
I'm sorry what
they're not wrong I mean you're not
wrong that's why there's you get Sight
and Sound here that's it you don't
luckily YouTube hasn't found a way to
project my stink over to you
soon we'll have the technology soon
smell-o-vision is coming
you know what's funny this section of
our script is always outlined as uh
Bruce banter because we've always had
banter in there and at some point over
the past 18 months it just evolved into
Bruce Banton we colored it green and I'm
so glad now we have a you know it
finally applies to the series we're
covering so that's fun Bruce banter and
now in this episode of inside Marvel
Jessica and Mt and I will be discussing
how She-Hulk really got her powers and
what it means that hulks metabolize
faster than normal people and what the
deal was with that Johnny Blaze poster
in the behind the scenes futuret what's
going on there and Jessica since you're
new here why don't you ask the question
yes ask the question I can ask it
okay how did Bruce de-power to human
form to give Jen his blood in the first
place and why did his blood Hulk out
anyone else yes that is uh the question
there's actually like four questions
here that we'll get to but in the
Seahawk comics of course Jennifer
Walters gets her powers after she gets
shot by criminals that she's Prosecuting
so her cousin Bruce Banner gives her uh
a blood transfusion that saves her life
but this Blood now in her blood system
causes her to Hulk out the MCU version
of these events was always going to pose
a complication of this story though
because Hulk ended endgame in a
permanent smart Hulk form but his arm
was injured and left in that sling after
he tried to snap the six stones and was
successful but it kind of charred his
arm uh but you gotta imagine no needle
is gonna be able to penetrate that skin
because he's still Hulk you know he
could shoot at him you can try to stab
him it's not going to break through the
skin but uh sunshi post credit scene
showed Ruffalo back you know in his
human form wearing that sling though and
now all the footage we see of him and
She-Hulk puts him back in Hulk form
there was something back in the Disney
plus tape but it's where it looked like
a kind of dream sequence or some kind of
like cutaway some kind of fantasy thing
where you see him in kind of the early
David Banner Hulk TV show uh attire but
and everything we've seen since we
haven't seen that but then last week's
behind the scenes feature it revealed
how this Shield series is going to
explain how Jennifer Walters gets her
powers let's roll the clip Jennifer
Walters is an attorney who has
accidentally taken in the Hulk's blood
okay
examine this more closely both jyn and
Bruce are both in human form in this car
accident the car has flipped Jen's arm
is positioned under Bruce's bleeding
head and his blood gets on her we just
gotta assume that Jen herself has some
Cuts or lacerations so that his blood
enters her bloodstream as opposed to
Just landing on her skin uh what's weird
though is that Bruce is wearing the
sling already at the start of his car
accident it's the same Sling from the
shangshi post credit scene and that
confirms that She-Hulk is not set during
the blip because you remember sunshi is
definitely said after the blit they
reference the blip there's like posters
referencing the blip and everything but
Bruce is already wearing that sling
before this car accident occurs so there
must be some prior accident that
explained why he was in that sling and
that incident is likely why Bruce is
back in human form but back in uniform
temporarily because we know for the bulk
of the show he's going to be in smart
Hulk form so these are the four
questions that we're going to talk about
here one how did Hulk depower to Bruce
and why was his arm in that sling two
what causes a car accident three how how
will Bruce revert back to Hope form in
this series and four why is only Jen
Walters affected by Bruce's blood when
his blood has definitely gotten in other
characters over the years like famously
a drop of his blood fell from a you know
into that bottle of juice in the factory
in the 2008 and when Norton Hulk film
that later made several characters sick
including Stan Lee Marvel Studios has
clarified since then that those people
did not Hulk out they just got sick and
then also in the 2012 Avengers and you
know 2015 Age of Ultron it's likely that
when Hulk reverted a human form into
Ruffalo he probably had some Cuts some
blood probably got exposed to someone
you know Natasha Romanov helped him limp
away from battles I'm sure his blood
gone on her uh so let's take these in
reverse order talk about each one
um so uh why did it only affect Jen I'm
thinking guys that Jen has some kind of
unique genetic conditions so that only
she would react this way to uh having
her Cuts make contact with Bruce's blood
maybe it's just familial DNA maybe it's
an X Gene but it's just something that
she has and no one else has and Stan
Lee's character would not have had it
what do you guys think why was generally
affected I completely agree
I'm sorry I completely agree I think it
is only because it's only in the family
and if it did alter anyone else maybe
her parents or what have you it still
has to be someone that's in the Bruce
Banner family because I do think they're
going to still keep on attack that 2008
rule of if someone else drinks it
they're going to just become crazy
people so I don't think that that's too
far off to just be like oh I don't think
it's going to be the X Gene I think it's
that she's in the family and people with
that same genetic makeup can have it and
that's why hers isn't probably as
horrible as his is true but we also
should consider um the end of the 2008
Hulk film when uh the leader
um got a drops a couple drops of Bruce's
blood on his forehead and his forehead
was like oh time to change and be weird
um so I think that Bruce's blood can
affect anyone really but like it really
depends it's sort of like a crap shoot
sort of like um with the extremist
program like half of the veterans that
had an extremist blew up because their
bodies just weren't compatible with a
straight alteration so I think that it
really is just like you might die you
might get powers really it really just
depends on what your chemical makeup is
there just has to be a reason to get a
serum
I wasn't it was it just Bruce's raw
blood that got into I thought there was
like some other kind of process to where
there was like a serum derived from it
that was used to make Abomination and
that they had done something extra to it
Beyond it just being what was currently
I I'd have to re-watch it I'd have to
rewatch it if you do bring up a good
point empty yeah I think if I'm
remembering correctly it's been a while
since I've watched it too I think that
like while Abomination is changing uh
Sam gets hit by Samuel Stearns gets hit
like falls back and like some of his
blood uh boost his blood falls on his
forehead he's like oh this is good and
we never see him again
um but yeah I I think that like this
accident could occur
um some point like a lot closer to the
events of end game because like I think
that Bruce at the point of this accident
is still healing and probably can't Hulk
out and uh maybe that like some of Jen's
enemies like work
um based on a case that she's working on
want her to be dead so like she's riding
with Bruce one day it's like all right
Bruce isn't gonna Hulk out because he's
he's hurt and like you know they're both
vulnerable so let's just attack them
both and uh like some of Bruce's blood
gets in her bloodstream he's like all
right time to beat oh she helped now Mt
you're touching on such an interesting
Theory you're getting you're getting
ahead of us but I want to talk to you
more about that and so I'm sorry but let
no this is awesome I I love where this
is going let's actually talk about that
why was Bruce's arm in a sling right
that's still kind of an unknown question
since we saw him in the sunshi post
credit scene but now that we know that
Wong is in this series I firmly believe
that phase four is the Wong phase they
need to just call it the one maze Wong
is in everything yeah get them in
everything
um but uh so we know that Bruce spanner
is in touch with Wong the sorcerer
Supreme from that scene and my theory
that I posed before is that Wong might
have used a temporary depowering spell
like the Sands of nasanti that we saw in
Multiverse of Madness that uh de-power
you for like a certain amount of time uh
and that they might have depowered Hulk
so that they could heal his arm after it
was a burned in endgame and they needed
to de-power him into human form to heal
it because it couldn't really do
anything to him while he was still in
Hulk form and that that might be why
just temporarily he's in the sling
during this period of time the sorcerers
have been helping him out
um it could just be like a simple scene
in the first episode of She-Hulk where
they just kind of say that where it's
like Wong help me out he got me back to
the human form and then he uh
they tried to operate with Hulk but it
broke their their magical objects so
they needed me back in a human form
it's such a rough but good Mark Ruffalo
impression
I can see that and I can also see MTS my
whole situation is I think I I we kind
of glazed over the fact that it took him
so long to even balance coexist between
stupid Hulk and smart Hulk and himself
so I think there is I think there's
still room for him after end game to be
like yeah I went back to the lab and I
focused more on now seeing how I can
change between the two rather than just
uh just becoming smart Hulk he's like I
want to make sure that we can coexist
but also I can be one or the other but I
think his arm is still in that sling
because that's something that just can't
be fixed yet and I think he's been
spacing he's been focusing so much on
himself and I think that's what's going
to be like the big story of She-Hulk is
focusing on yourself and being yourself
that that's what he's been focusing on
rather than fixing the arm that's messed
up if that makes sense but I do agree
with mt going forward about the whole
incident happening I think someone's out
to kill Jennifer Walters and that's why
the car flipped I agree with umt on that
that's ahead of us
yeah uh but yeah that's interesting yeah
yeah um let's not forget about Helen Joe
from uh Age of Ultron because like her
whole deal was repairing people's skins
like she uh she helped Hawkeye she made
Vision so I feel like uh there's also a
possibility that Bruce is on his way to
go meet up with Hill and Joe to help his
arm out it's been too long and I'm upset
it's been I I'm upset with her because
it's been too long I'm like you think
you would have helped people three
movies ago or like a three movie three
series ago there's a lot of people
missing skin you can't pick and choose
she's she's using her skin grafting
technology to be like Buffalo Bill she's
somewhere like dancing shoes
she's making a tick tock video going
like I'd [ __ ] me
also she just wanted the green skin she
wanted the green skin she said give it
exactly
I agree I think we need Helen show back
in this because how do you think we're
gonna get Amadeus
boy could she have a Sunday Mama Deus
gosh
that's gotta be amadeus's Mom right I
mean there's only uh there's only one
way two people could have the same last
name of Cho it's not like it's my last
name
one way ever in this show we gotta see
how Bruce reverts back from Ruffalo to
Hulk form right after the sling because
in all this footage she doesn't have a
sling anymore I'm wondering if like
whatever my theory if I'm still going
with this sorcerer healing seminar
Theory like maybe the Santa desanti wear
off and maybe maybe it could be like the
destruction of the dark hole through the
book of Ashanti that disrupts sorcerer
magic Across the Universe uh or maybe it
could just be like Bruce just kind of
reverts back to what you were saying
Jess like it's about you know healing
yourself and finding finding your inner
kind of balance like he's just really
good at meditating enough to reach back
to that that kind of weird edging state
that he States
but also uh but you spoke about this
earlier a little bit and I agree it's
like so so he heals quicker right when
he's in Hulk form than he would as just
a normal human Bruce Banner right so
could it be that he doesn't need the
sling because he's like kind of fully
kind of not fully but like more healed
clearly than when he reverts back into
his human Bruce Banner form where he'd
still be injured is that or maybe he
could be wearing the sling just to look
injured still because there's something
he's hiding that he's like in the public
I need to look like I'm so broken but in
reality I'm actually not broken
[Laughter]
uh She-Hulk clearly there's a lot of
issues of She-Hulk where when she's like
oh I'm beating down I'm going to be
Jennifer Walters but when I'm actually
confident in myself I become actual
She-Hulk I think the same could go for
Bruce Banner when he's like people
outside know me as like I'm broken and
I'm in hiding right now no one needs to
find me I'm on the run so he has that
sling when he's only in Bruce Banner
form but when he goes in the Hulk he's
like I don't actually need this I'm in
privacy now I don't know I don't I I
don't know he could I don't know it
could be a lot of things but are you
saying it's gonna be like The Rock in
Fast and Furious 7 when he like flexes
out of his cast
[Laughter]
we need Bruce to do that at some point
it's like oh I'm awkward now
I hope not but also maybe
possibly who knows no I do think at some
point in this series we're going to see
Bruce Hulk out into Gray Hulk and we're
gonna get Joe fix it yeah
um who's like the like the little like
Vegas Gambler type of version of Hulk
because like it seems like he's just
like really jealous of Jen and like I
feel like it's at the end of the series
he's gonna be like I'm gonna be somebody
else because Jen's so gonna be in the
Hulk I want to be somebody else and be
good at doing I don't know crime she's
like you know what that's right I should
be someone else and then goes into
gambling gambling
Vegas it's a dirt bag right isn't he
kind of yeah he's kind of a jerk for
sure but like I feel like the MCU is
headed to the West Coast in Vegas and
like we know we have that biggest
episode what if so like I just feel like
Vegas is the way to go
maybe I'd love to see him there I think
it'd be a really fun version of the
character for Ruffalo to play right
right um but yeah let's come back to
this car wreck okay so yeah it could be
an accident it could actually be while
Bruce and Jen are arguing maybe one or
both of them are hulking out but I think
it's more interesting if it's like a
targeted hit right it's a drone strike
maybe dodc the Thunderbolts maybe Val
could Val have done it empty go off what
were your thoughts on this oh um it
could be all sorts of people um it could
be like one of Bruce's enemies because
we know that Val like you just said I
was going after Hawkeye so like maybe
just Val's just trying to get rid of all
the Avengers for some reason and uh
Bruce was just on that Target and like
Bruce has never been more vulnerable
than while he's in this swing so he's
just like all right we can't not take
this shot because like we went for
Hawkeye it didn't work out so like yeah
let's go for Bruce because like this is
the only time we're gonna be able to
kill this man
um if we're gonna like introduce our own
Thunderbolts and sort of take over
Society
um yeah so I feel like yeah that was a
huge Contender here I think
it's Wilson Fisk and this is this isn't
Rogue Theory so I'm not going to get too
into it I can save it for then but I do
really I'm hooked on Matt Murdoch being
in the show I'm hooked on Matt Burdock
being on the show and I'm hooked on them
working I think that her boss was so
nonchalant about being Bruce Banner's uh
relative because he was like we need big
name people we need you Prosecuting
bigger name people so when she starts
becoming She-Hulk and Prosecuting bigger
name people I think she's working
Prosecuting people and Titania is going
to be working defending people and I
think that person that they're
Prosecuting and defending is someone
that worked for Wilson Fisk that is
trying to take her out because they
don't want to lose to her because in the
comics between Matt Murdoch and Jennifer
Walters even Captain America said
Jennifer Walters was the better lawyer
so
I just I just wanted to be that it
connects to Echo it connects it keeps
going make it a long run thing
I love that idea I mean we do know that
Jennifer Walters is the uh is the better
lawyer I mean she did defend Eros yeah
um she didn't get a not guilty verdict
for him
okay we're not wrong but
um I I do I love this uh connection to
fist considering that like we know from
like the Hawkeye series that like Fisk
is this super soldier of a human that
can rip doors off and like I would love
if like She-Hulk connected
um the whole uh Hulk's connection to the
super soldier program to Fisk and like
maybe explaining how Fisk is so powerful
um in the MCU because like there's it
has not been explained why Fisk is like
this tank of a human being so I feel
like it's really fun if he was connected
to this this show is just all the tanks
of the MCU I'm gonna be I'm gonna be I'm
just gonna be like these are all people
that are just really strong none of them
can fly none of them have any magic
strongest people on the planet everybody
in this world like titanium like Titania
could have a titanium the gamma super
soldier program
yeah I can't wait I can't wait I love
her all right a couple more questions
that we want to dig into for She-Hulk
this week but first some friends who
helped us make this episode thank you to
Helix sleep for sponsoring this episode
sleep is important and here at new
rockstars We Trust Helix to protect our
sleep with the best mattresses in the
world I have a helix mattress as does MT
recently producer Zach and producer John
oh we're all sleep on a helix mattresses
we're all sleeping on the same mattress
if you think about it just all of us
connected cosmically through our friends
at Helix and every night we whisper in
each other's ears
and we dream about uh future threats to
Target and it's beautiful the best sleep
of Our Lives thanks Helix Helix sleep is
a quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete and matches your body type and
your sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you everyone's unique and
Helix knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses that are great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains even
Helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers producer Zach took the Helix
quiz and was matched with the midnight
Lux mattress because he's a side sleeper
that needed a softer mattress and now he
doesn't wake up with a sore shoulder or
neck problems like he did with other
mattresses you might be able to see that
on the break room just look how upright
our boy stands now you can thank Helix
for that uh he's straight as a narrow
that guy but a helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2021 by GQ and Wired Magazine just go to
helixsleep.com inside Marvel take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress they'll
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty gonna get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
Helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com inside
marble we also want to thank the
commercial break comedy podcast for
sponsoring the show the commercial break
is like a real life commercial break
from all the series things going on in
the world two long time friends Brian
and Chrissy discuss their friendship
stories from their personal life in a
deeper look at some of the Absurd Trends
and topics that they find on the
internet wild stuff like people who date
ghosts strange ASMR videos and Monster
Hunters is like goofing around with your
friends the commercial break has a 4.9
star rating on Apple and was chartable's
number one trendy podcast globally three
times in the past year commercial break
has new episodes each Monday Wednesday
and Friday on all podcast players and
full episodes and daily Clips are
available on their YouTube channel at
youtube.com the commercial break or you
can visit tcbpodcast.com for more info
that's tcbpodcast.com so go ahead take a
listen to our new paid friends on the
commercial break everywhere you like to
listen to your podcast or visit
tcpodcast.com all right uh guys let's go
back into this conversation of all Buzz
no barf um I'm gonna get this tattooed
on me somewhere what's going on with
their ability to metabolize drinking I
have a theory that maybe Bruce got in a
car accident because he was back in
human form and he forgot how to moderate
his drinking could that have been it
Bruce DUI confirmed uh what does this
mean for the characters of this world
that they that they just drink and drink
and drink and drink this is also applied
to their food are they going to ruin our
Foods or Global food supply to more
hulks we have you sound like Thanos
what was boss cooking it was a monster
what was he cooking I think it'd be
really interesting for um Marvel Studios
to dive into the the topic of drunk
driving and like it's really terrible
effects but I think that because it is
Disney plus they probably wouldn't go
that route
um because I'm not wrong boss but
no I just appreciate Mt giving this this
take
um some proper due diligence when you
know you know it's it's really not good
I I would really commend Marvel Studios
if they actually went down that road
just to show people how dangerous drunk
driving is and like how it could
completely ruin your life if you're not
a Hulk which most people are not so like
I I would give them Kudos if they went
that route but like I don't think that
they'll actually
um encourage the the children it's like
hey drink driving maybe your cousin will
become a superhero like all right
kind of a bad message I think that
Target on your back was like an actual
was an actual like warning of like we
have Targets on our backs now like you
had a Target before because you're a
lawyer I also like they even said in
that interview of like yeah we're trying
to make like a Marvel show and a lawyer
show and if I I watch a lot of Law and
Order SVU they they do have Targets on
their backs all the time they're being
chased all the time and I think it's
more it's going to be like a Venn
diagram of being a Hulk being a lawyer
what do they have in common and it's
just like a lot more than CSI you're
gonna be targeted all the time
um but watch it watch it on the show
it'd just be like a a freaking like
sloth crossing the street and they like
squirt out of the way or something
just like no Bruce don't
need them are sloths in Mexico I think
so who if they if they travel far enough
for a very long time they can they're
like survive I finally made it to Mexico
but I think I I love that quote also
about their like the alcohol but I think
it's going to be a problem to Jennifer
because there's a bunch of cuts to the
uh they have it in the comics the lawyer
bar that all the lawyers go to after
work they hang out at that bar where
they're chanting like She Hulk She-Hulk
and I'm like damn your tab's gonna be so
high now you are never gonna get drunk
again and you were really hoping to
probably after a lawyer day so I think
it was fun a fun little nod
yeah yeah
um okay we have to talk about this the
Johnny Blaze poster that showed up in
the behind the scenes featurette is this
just a little Easter egg I mean is Ghost
Rider coming to the MCU do you think
we'll see like a midnight Sun's
announcement at d23 absolutely
absolutely I think that's because oh no
you can go no go keep going you might
answer my question that I'm about to ask
so go oh I'm gonna go it's kind of weird
but because we know that like um well
sorry because we're like we're figuring
that's the Earth 616 is a very universe
of the Agents of Shield Universe there
was a Johnny Blaze in that universe so
like it there has to be a Johnny Blaze
in this universe somewhere so uh I think
that that is for sure a tease of a
Johnny Blaze existing the MCU and that
um She-Hulk is probably gonna have some
type of dealings with John or maybe you
like go get a cameo but like I think
we're definitely gonna get a midnight
Suns with a Johnny Blaze
um in the MCU very soon
I have a question to you Mt go for it I
have a question you don't think this is
going to be a Ralph boner you don't
think this is going to be I'm gonna be
do you not think that this is gonna be
what did they say they said that like
when you um they said in Multiverse
Madness when you um you dream you're
seeing your other like uh other selves
in different realities do you think the
writer for that movie is like in a
different reality Johnny Blaze and which
was like I don't I want it to be here I
want it to be here but I just don't I
don't know how I don't I don't believe
it yet I think he's in a different
Universe Am I Wrong Am I Wrong for
thinking this
I I think that there's just multiple
Johnny blazes I think that like this is
gonna be a different Johnny Blaze than
the one we saw from the ages of Shield
universe or like the um the Nicholas
Cage Johnny Blaze I think like this is
just a a new Johnny Blaze
um and but I think that we'll get the
same
um Gabriel oh it's Gabriel Luna right um
yeah yes uh the other one yeah gamer
Luna played him in Agents of Shield I
forget the the name of the I I still do
think that Robbie Reyes is coming like
the very same version from Asians of
Shield is coming in Doctor Strange three
because we know that hell exists in the
dark dimension and Doctor Strange went
to the dark dimension at the end of
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness so do we know that hell exists
in the dark dimension I think
um it was set in ages I think hell
exists in the MCU I just where do where
do they say now you got me fascinated
I'm like I I'm pretty sure that um
Agents of Shield established that Hal
um exists the dark dimensions let me
just double check here I see okay okay
um dark dimension
Agents of Shield
I think it's like a it's a region of the
dark dimension it's like hell I don't
know but anyway
um I think that
um because he went to the dark dimension
I think that they're both going to meet
up and be like oh hey let's do a team up
because people love you people love me
let's do the doctor strange Robbie Reyes
team up why not yeah what if it is just
do we know if it was a it it's so grainy
that image is it a poster for like a
movie or a circus yeah that's what had
me curious because it's like uh it's
like a character called uh Johnny Blaze
or an actor named Johnny Blaze exists in
the MCU it's not necessarily unless
they're doing like a docu series or a
biopic biopic about a guy named Johnny
Blaze it's kind of like in the deleted
scene or the deleted imagery for
Guardians Volume 2 had a movie poster
for Wonder Man right like like there was
kind of like but wonder man makes a bit
more sense it's just like Simon Williams
was an actor playing like it was like a
Steve Jobs type figure right right uh so
that was the idea it's always confusing
when there's like a movie poster or some
kind of like book title or comic book
that shows like uh because Johnny Blaze
was a daredevil like his whole thing was
like you know being on a motorcycle and
doing like weird tricks and and flaming
Hoops so like I think that that could be
an ad for that come see Johnny Blaze do
a motorcycle through a flaming hoop
that's why I asked is it for a circus or
is it for a movie also what if it is
just a guy that like lights his helmet
on fire and jumps the Rings honestly
but that's all it is that's all he ever
does I think I think we'd all be a
little sad I wouldn't I'd be so up to it
give me more
um well we will leave it there for now
for She-Hulk but we're gonna talk a lot
more about She-Hulk in the weeks ahead
next week we'll be talking She-Hulk
again on inside Marvel and then
she-hulk's gonna be here
for the next for the next couple months
it's gonna be an exciting exciting time
uh But be sure to follow all of us on
social media follow me at EA bossy
follow Jessica at Lulu underscore
clemency calllo Mt and ascertainment uh
subscribe to inside Marvel wherever you
get your podcast subscribe to new
rockstars thank you all so much for
supporting us and we'll see you next
week that I ever been hi everybody love
you guys
foreign